[Música]
el hecho de ser mujer no fue percibido o
ha sido percibido
para mí como un obstáculo nunca lo
percibía así todo lo contrario me parece
que ser mujer ha sido
es a ese ingrediente que ha marcado el
hilo de mi camino de lo que he hecho
mucho poco de lo que he hecho de esa
sensibilidad que da probablemente el
género pero no nada más sensibilidad y
las ganas que el deseo de cuidar de
proteger de atender quizás muy
probablemente eso llevó al camino
entonces esa mujer
en mi caso particularmente no fue
percibido no ha sido percibido como un
obstáculo
y bueno siendo adolescente yo me voy a
montar a la década de 80 biglia digo los
80 en la cuenta de edad
en 1988 en el cuerpo se del periódico
nacional un domingo leo el artículo
titulado el cáncer gay
y el cáncer y ese título enseguida hizo
en mi género en mi curiosidad y lo
consumir de la alacena muy rápidamente y
me intrigó era el momento de la ub del
inicio de la pandemia del vih
y eso generó fue el clean que hizo a mi
deseo de ser médico le puso el objetivo
ayudar a apoyar a las personas que
tenían ese nuevo virus del cual no se
conocía el origen no se sabía que
producía se describió en unas manchas
negras en la piel que era el sarcoma de
kaposi y más que el impacto físico era
el impacto personal en las vidas de
discriminación de las personas que
vivían con vih 10a definitivamente a los
buenos en la adolescencia fue el hilo
conductor que me llevo y que seguramente
me está llevando hasta este momento y
para el año 2019 30 millones de personas
vivían con vih y desde la década de los
80 hasta hoy han muerto más de 30
millones de personas por el virus del
vih más o menos 50 por ciento
que hoy viven con vih son mujeres y en
aproximadamente 2 millones de los 30 son
niños adolescentes por debajo de 15 años
lo más impactante probablemente estos
números que adquirieron el vih de sus
padres en el momento del embarazo en el
momento del nacimiento por lactancia
materna pero aún más para mí impactante
de saber que la mayoría si no la
totalidad de estas infecciones se pueden
prevenir con unos pasos con una vez es
tan sencillo como hacer un control del
embarazo adecuado hacer el diagnóstico y
ponerle tratamiento a la madre nuestros
pasos médicos pero esos digamos 23
puntos son los que condicionan que un
niño del vih versos que no lo tengan y
que tengo una familia impactada por este
vídeo entonces definitivamente eso es un
motor el motor de ayudar el motor del
dar y se genera para mí la magia y la
satisfacción de estar de ayudar y eso
fue digamos esa motivación eso ha sido
la pgje
que se ha puesto en el río para ir
pasando de un sitio al otro con él dice
olvidar y el deseo de apoyar eso me
llevó al año 2015 cuando el programa
nacional decida decide ver qué está
pasando con la población cuadrado de
venezuela la población indígena del
delta del delta amacuro detecta del
orinoco y bueno nos invitan a participar
a ir a tucupita un viaje de 10 horas en
carretera donde sabemos que nos lleva a
esa población que hay que decir ellos
querían estudiar esto porque se ha
calculado por estudios previos que un 10
por ciento de esa población tenía vih y
cuando decimos 10% estamos hablando de
100 poblaciones pequeñas en aplicación
con por ciento es demasiado es demasiado
y han despertado la alarma entonces 10
por ciento de la población tan
concentrada está encerrada es un
problema definitivamente grave fuimos
allá 10 horas
de caracas a tucupita en carro digamos
en la noche y en la madrugada había que
despertarse porque había que estar en el
delta muy muy temprano había que salir
para allá antes de las doce del mediodía
bueno a los seis de la mañana estábamos
en aquel muelle yo le voy a llamar
muelle a lamentablemente que la especie
de gigante basurero donde había muchos
desechos además muchas personas en busca
de transporte y de oportunidades de
oportunidades diversas allí dentro de un
conglomerado de muchas personas
hoy me llama la atención la voz de un
extranjero y esto llama la atención
delante de aquel ruido y volteo y veo a
un médico una mujer médico
con una familia papá mamá y yo en brazos
a un bebé y sin pensar me acerque y
pregunte por qué estaba mal y qué pasaba
y la doctora me cuenta que tenía cinco
horas en la espera de una ambulancia
porque el niño estaba enfermo
en ese momento los estamos veo un bebé
pálido partido tocó está muy frío y se
incorpora en mí y una fuerza y un coraje
para mí increíble cuando lo veo en
retrospectiva que ordenó a la guardia
nacional abrir el fuerte porque ese
mismo había examinar si esa familia
estaba esperando en la pared por fuera
de fuerza de la guardia nacional abre la
puerta porque quiso mirar este niño no
viene está enfermo abre la puerta
examinó al niño y era también era tarde
después que lo estoy examinando a los
10-15 minutos
llegó una ambulancia
igual decidido subir allí a la familia
para atenderlo para poner el oxígeno y
donde nos dice que el niño había
fallecido tenían cinco horas grande para
editar la mamá aquí con su bebé el niño
aparentaba humano cuando pregunto la
edad tenía cinco años tenían cinco días
con diarrea ese mismo murió
y era el principio de media gente está
acá yo no había no me había montado en
la lancha que me iba a llevar a la
población de 4 horas íntimas
bueno tenía miedo por supuesto no quería
ya no quería ir y dirige marc y blinda
el corazón porque si estoy llegando que
vas a encontrar en la población bueno
fueron nueve horas de río salimos
después de la una del mediodía
llegamos en la noche que la luz super
peligrosos peligroso por las condiciones
de la travesía peligroso por el río y
por respirar en el río llegamos
finalmente fueron cuatro días de trabajo
las personas con villa ciudadanos
picados sospechando de esto fueron a la
escuela que en un palafito establecí
palafito y eran filas de personas filas
y yo con el equipo como una bolsa cada
tratamiento antiretroviral y muchos
espectadores bien viendo lo que estaba
ocurriendo y sistemáticamente entregando
tratamientos para mí su real era nada
más había visto eso por televisión en
algunas imágenes de áfrica y así fue el
viaje de regreso otras 9 horas nos
quedamos sin gasolina porque el lanchero
vendió gasolina y no calculó bien y nos
quedamos parados en gasolina finalmente
llegamos y terminó el viaje y hace una
semana como sobre 2015 y hace unas
semanas una representante de una agencia
internacional me dice que está
organizando un viaje al delta
y lo primero que digo yo voy
prácticamente tengo que está loca otra
vez lo que era el aprendizaje de la
magia delgada el motor que es el apoyo a
los más vulnerables este esta magia que
hace la satisfacción que da equipo magia
por la satisfacción personal
probablemente es una historia dura pero
es una historia que más que lo que yo he
dado y recibido inmensamente por dar son
apenas pinceladas del dar y eldad fue
construyendo el edificio en el cual
probablemente se sustenta muchos
yo particularmente como médico encontré
una satisfacción plena en esa edad sin
embargo cualquier persona en su ámbito
bien sea laboral familiar donde se
desenvuelva puede encontrar la magia
verdad porque créanme que va a recibir
mil veces más de lo que da